many people ask me questions about stoic
philosophy
and practice i've created this series to
provide short answers to the most common
recurring or confusing questions about
stoicism
excellent question about stoicism that
gets asked over and over
is is stoicism compatible
with other belief systems and it gets
asked in terms of specific belief
systems quite often but it also gets
asked
as a general question so
in answering this we really need to
think
about three different aspects of this we
want to think
about the question well what do you
actually
mean by compatible we want to
clarify what is meant by
belief systems and we also interestingly
enough
have to be kind of careful about what we
mean
by stoicism in this case and i think
that's really the best
place to begin because
we want to be very clear about the
kind of stoicism that we're asking about
so there are multiple interpretations of
stoicism
out there in the present some of them
will say are more superficial some
are much closer to the core of
classical stoicism and involves some
sort of modern
application or reinterpretation of this
so at the very start we want to
put aside very superficial treatments of
stoicism where people are saying it's
it's a set of life hacks
or here's the five you know principles
of stoicism
or any of that sort of stuff because
that's not actually stoicism that's just
a few
ideas derived from stoicism slapped into
a blog post or somebody's
you know coaching video or something
like that and it's not
it's not the actual philosophy itself so
it's not very helpful to talk about that
we also want to put aside
basically mistaken or even
exploitative notions of stoicism or
interpretations of that
so i'm going to talk about what we
sometimes
call stoicism written with a dollar sign
for the s and that's often quite
superficial but there'll be some sort of
you know systematic thing laid out for
people about how stoicism is going to
make you super productive
and able to make tons and tons of money
and
maybe not even have to sleep well that's
not really stoicism
either and we also want to put aside the
the deformation of philosophy that i
i even hesitate to call stoicism we
actually jokingly call it broicism
because it's it's you know calling a
bunch of quotes about
toughness and manliness and
you know emphasizes the importance of
courage
gets virtue wrong construing it you know
in terms of manliness
because you know it comes from the word
viewer and
that's not actual stoicism either
although there's a huge market out there
for people who are like you know talking
about how their stoics at the gym
and so tough man and and sometimes
talking about it in terms of
um ethnonationalism and you know a lot
of
sort of misogynist stuff as well so
let's put all that stuff aside we're not
going to worry too much about that
at this point if we do that
then we can talk about one big divide
and that is between those who call
themselves traditional stoics and those
the much larger group that call
themselves
modern stoic so traditional stoics would
say that
modern stoics have given in on
too many key stoic doctrines you know
for example
is the universe providentially arranged
according to some
vast cosmic rationality or is that not
the case
traditional stoics would say yes that's
basically almost like an article of
faith
and many modern stoics would say well i
don't know about that or
it doesn't seem to be that way or they
can say that it is
there's a lot more variance within
modern stoicism
and you know i would say that if we want
to call something modern stoicism it has
to be robust it has to be grounded
in classical stoicism but it doesn't
have to necessarily
be bound by everything that epictetus or
seneca
or musonius rufus or marcus aurelius
said
prime example is i do have a beard and
epictetus thinks that that's really you
know
more in accordance with nature for men
to have beards i think we can dispense
with that and
and i don't even think that the
traditional stoics think that we need to
hold on to
things along those lines so that's
that probably the stoicism that we're
talking about and
if you have read a lot of classic stoic
literature
i'm talking about epictetus and seneca
and you know accounts of these people
you actually know that stoicism itself
was not a rigid orthodoxy seneca
actually weighs
in about this and says you know we get
to decide
so long as there's sort of a core there
what we're going to
focus on and you notice that seneca is
perfectly willing to take things
even from the epicureans if he thinks
that they got things right
middle stoicism with posidonius and
peneteus were engaging in some serious
consideration of whether maybe some of
the other uh virtue ethics traditions
like platonism and aristotelianism
were getting things right so you know
it's not as if stoicism ever had a
you must think just these ways kind of
view
but we can say that there's a vast
network of ideas
and you don't want to lose too many of
them so
that said let's talk about compatibility
well what do we mean in saying that one
belief system
is compatible with the other there's a
couple ways we could construe this
one would be to say that there are no
fundamental contradictions between them
so they can fit together sort of like my
fingers are doing here
or like legos that click into each other
whatever it's going to be we might also
think of it
in culinary metaphors you can pair this
drink
with this dish and they're going to work
well together this one over here you
can't you know
like when you you drink orange juice
after just brushing your teeth most
people
find that disagreeable on a gustatory
level that's almost like a
a contradiction that is being registered
so is stoicism going to be compatible
in that sense with some belief systems
um you know
this is where we get to other things
maybe compatible doesn't mean that you
have to be in total agreement
but it means that in large respect the
two can
fit in with each other that they overlap
with each other
and you can say stoicism is definitely
compatible with other belief systems in
that respect
even with the you know their great
enemies
uh and polemicists in antiquity even
with epicureans to some degree
right the epicureans recognized for
cardinal virtues and said that you
should aim at them they just did it for
different reasons there's there's going
to be some fundamental
incompatibilities and you know another
thing that we want to think about and
this is very important
the stoic texts that we have don't cover
everything
and they they wouldn't even if we had
all of the stoic literature
because we live in a time 2000 years
and more after some of them were
composed
so you know there's going to be some
things that are what we call
under determined and in in some cases
perhaps some other belief systems could
or or approaches could be not just
compatible
but complementary with stoicism they
could
help each other out so let's think about
belief systems and which ones might be
more
or less compatible with stoicism
provided that we're understanding
stoicism again not as a rigid orthodoxy
where there's like a checklist but
rather almost like a constellation of
key concepts
you can you can maybe leave some of them
out and compromise on some
but others have to be have to be
retained or it's not stoicism
so is it compatible with other virtue
ethics
or with what we might say other
philosophies
as ways of life it will be compatible
with them
on a lot of accounts saying that justice
is an important virtue stoics
say that so do epicureans so to
plateness so do aristotelians
so do christian theorists right coming
after them
and responding to them and sometimes
incorporating them so do
for example utilitarians um
there's a number of of belief systems
and and
ways of living philosophy that would be
quite compatible with that
and we could also talk about you know
what about other metaphysical or
religious
concepts obviously if we're thinking in
terms of the
traditional stoic understanding of the
cosmos
and reason and divinity it's not going
to be
entirely compatible with say the
epicurean view which is that there's
gods but they don't care anything about
human beings
or you know contemporary atheism or
christianity or judaism or islam or
really anything that says that there's
some sort of
transcendent creator god it's not going
to be compatible with
with theistic versions of buddhism like
pure land buddhism
there's going to be a lot of places
where you've got to say well i can buy
this or buy this and that's okay
you know there may be some places where
a modern stoic
may say listen i don't accept the
notion of the universe bursting into
flames every so often and then being
reconstituted in this eternal
repetition of the same i i just don't
buy that
and i don't buy it because i accept this
other belief system over here
but the rest of stoicism you know its
views on the emotions its views on
uh anthropology its views on us having a
sort of uh common uh human nature
that includes uh a sociality
okay i i buy that because that fits in
with with these sorts of things
um so you know we could talk about uh
other ethics other ways of being and i
think there's going to be some that are
just
not going to be compatible with much of
stoicism
for example i mentioned you know forms
of ethnic nationalism
really going to go against stoic
cosmopolitanism which is not something
that i think you can
effectively strip out of stoicism
because it's got
its roots in so many other key doctrines
uh including you know oikiosis or
appropriation
including the nature of justice
including
our very nature as human beings i think
if you get rid of the cosmopolitanism
you've probably not got stoicism anymore
so there's a major contradiction there
i would say that stoicism is not going
to be compatible
with you know objectivism as set forth
by ein rand in its
various different interpretations by the
different warring
tribes of randians out there as well
because this emphasis on rationality is
good but the emphasis on
rationality is fundamentally
self-centered and selfish
there's going to be some fundamental
incompatibilities there
as well and so i think that there's
there's we can talk in terms of
not just compatibility as being like an
on off switch but being like a spectrum
there's going to be some things over
here that are just really not compatible
being
like a hardcore consumerist and thinking
that
piling up as many goods as you can
that's not compatible with stoicism
and you know it's incompatible in so
many ways being a
misogynist jim bro who you know wants to
hang out with his dudes
and talk about how he's defending
western civilization
even if they bring in stoicism not
really compatible with genuine stoicism
and we could go on and on and on with
other things so you want to look at what
the commitments are
to that particular belief system and way
of living that belief system
and what genuine stoicism would would
say in in place of that i think that
it's perfectly legitimate to wrap this
up
for a person to say well i haven't
figured it all
out but i want to hold on to as much as
stoicism as i can
and as much of this other belief system
over here because i also
find value in that at a certain point
you actually do have to like as
a good friend of mine used to say you
pay your money and you take your chances
right
so like think about aristotelianism and
stoicism
on what it takes for us to be happy
there are some fundamental
incompatibilities although both of them
say
virtue and virtuous activity are at the
core of it the aristotelians are
insistent that you need to have
some fabric of relationships and you
also need to have some degree
of wealth or resources whereas the
stoics say those are nice if you can get
them
but you don't really need them there
you've got to decide which one
one or the other when it comes to the
nature of the human soul and how many
parts it has
stoics say there's one rational part and
that's where we feel emotions
platonists say there's three main parts
to it well you've got to decide one way
or the other and i'll mention too that
posidonius and
there's probably something to that
platonic doctrine so
it's not a really simple question to
answer
but hopefully going through these
distinctions and drawing out these
inferences
helps you if you're asking that sort of
question about
is stoicism compatible with other belief
systems the answer is
well yes to a degree depending on the
belief system
you